(cars driving nearby)
- (Mark) Alright Smiley Roo
- yeah, I'm back on the playground.
(car horn)
- Yeah, what's going on?
Man, you know, I just been, you know
things I did in my past,
man, you know what, you know
when they say your past,
come back to haunt you
you had a lot of things that I did, man.
It convicts me right today. You know
It steers me in the wrong places
you know, it's good that I got
God that pulled me back out.
But you know, I learned
at a young age that, uh,
gang banging, shit, I liked it, you know,
but all I was doing was killing
you know, my brothers, you know
and I'm not just meaning
skin color, but yeah
I was just killing my brothers.
And at some point I do mean skin color
because you have to look that way as well.
And first and deep, you
know, everybody wanted to be
with the business and play
these old tough guy games, man.
You know, I ain't no tough guy.
I just, I'm just me.
I get it with anybody,
having anybody win, lose
or draw, you know, you don't kill me
and we gonna be at it,
but that's nonsense.
We should all get along, man,
eliminate this shit away.
Kids don't have to grow up
to what I grew up through.
No kids, you know, my kids, you know
I started off young in the game man.
I thought it was my job to
make the Bloods and Crips
even. I really pursued it.
Like people that know that know that.
And, uh, people got
injured and other things,
you know, I'm not proud about it.
It's nothing to brag about.
I feel bad about it.
You know, I feel bad about
it, I feel guilty about it
because I said, I got older
I'm 52 years old now, you
know, I realized that's not it.
That's not the way, you know,
I feel bad when I look back
you know, the decisions that I made.
Um, yeah.
Yeah, I-
I'm in the trenches again, you know
I haven't been on top of the game.
I haven't been up out of the game.
I haven't been on the side of the game.
I'm back up under the game.
None of those books I did
and TV man, looking all-
I don't think about it bro
I'm with that shit, but I ain't.
But yeah man, I just
wanted to stress that man.
Cause nobody get on here
and they tell all they, they,
they bad stuff, you know?
And I got a lot of bad stuff, you know
but I thought that I would highlight
where
I went wrong
as to where some of you
other people could see
where you might be headed
down the same road because
if I know it's a thousand foot cliff
down in you come in that way.
I'll be like, Hey dude, turn around.
It's a thousand foot cliff
down here. Don't go that way.
And you keep going, I'm
gonna try to stop you.
But Hey, if that's your destiny,
then you know, bon voyage.
But you know, I'm going
to try to stop you.
And at the same time,
steer to the right road.
And that's why I'm on the Today, you know
I got on and I talked about my passion
and it looked like I was
glorifying the virus and all that.
But I don't really
glorified that, you know
I'm more of a peaceful man, and humble.
God, God got me going
through some trials just
to make me stronger.
I know that he won't put too much on you,
but it's tough man. It's tough, man.
It's like me against the world.
I really feel like that clock's on.
But at the same time, excuse me Father
I ain't even giving a
fuck, you know, bring it on
if that's what it is, you
know, I still gotta be me.
And everybody's like, Hey man, be careful.
(mumbles) fuck off
Imma be dangerous, and
keep them motherfuckers
from riding up on it.
They know you dangerous,
They ain't gonna let up on you.
They don't try to shoot you.
This, this, this I'm stay dangerous, man.
I don't give a fuck
about none of that, man.
I just want to appeal to everybody.
You know, all the racist, man I mean
Christmas is about to be upon us.
You know, um,
some Muslim celebration.
Man I mean bring some pieces
of the shit with at least a month
Back up out of the streets
man and doing people wrong
And all that and let's just
have some peace with them
and let's make a fuck-, let's
set a record in California
have some fucking peace, excuse me.
Some peace and some
holiday spirit, man,
you know,
better stop hurting each other
doing all this stuff that
don't nobody want done to them.
I mean you do it to somebody
but you don't want it done done.
You don't do that shit.
What the fuck? I mean, come on.
Another thing I want to get past was that
God is the one true living god,
people have many beliefs
but your belief come from
what God showed you.
Other people got other
guys that shows them things
like the devil. Ain't my
guy, but God showed me.
And there was a guy and don't
leave all that nonsense.
You know but, Man may have the Bible.
But the one thing they got straight
to there is a higher being
and that being will guide you
and will protect you and that scripture.
So I walked through the
Valley of the shadow of death.
I shall fear. That's the key to that.
I shall fear no evil.
If you start feeling,
you don't let God go.
You walked through that Valley.
You're going to get knocked down.
But I shall not fear. That's the key.
God say don't fear. So
God said, I don't know
let's do good, He said, don't feel
I'm going through my chest down.
My throat, fuck your finger too.
Whether you ain't, ain't
going to get arrogant.
But I mean it, shit, man, come on man.
You know, I know dudes like you youngsters
they get in the County
jail and think that,
that that scripture that says
the truth will set you free.
You go in the courtroom
and tell the judge everything
you did and get life.
That's not what that mean.
That means the truth will set
you free from the bondages
of sin, which is on a spiritual level,
not material.
So quit giving your lives away like that.
I just want to reiterate one thing, man.
Merry Christmas, happy New Year's.
Hope y'all had a good Thanksgiving.
I ain't had one in a while but
you know I'm still out here.
I'm toughing it out. I'm still in here.
My man got me on I'm back on.
I might write a rap next week.
My man had me on one of my
coach singing for you one day.
- (Mark) Alright, thanks smiley.